[Aplausos]
entonces de repente cuando en un
campamento científico te asignan un
grupo con tres amigos te dan un pedazo
de hilo y la consigna de calcular el
ancho de un arroyo
seguro se ponen a discutir y tratan de
ver qué hacen con él y lo cruzan el
arroyo mil veces tratan de ver cuántas
veces puede entrar el hilo en desarrollo
no sé se mojan y se cansan seguros
en una de esas muerta de frío agotada y
encima toda empapada me pregunte si no
había alguna forma de calcular ese ancho
sin tener que mojarme más
y entonces me paré a la orilla y comenzó
a observar y entendí que para iu se
formaban tres distancias la de mis pies
hacia mis ojos la de mi vista hacia los
de orilla y la de esa orilla hacia la
cual yo estaba para
y me acordé
su canto
un conocimiento básico de trigonometría
que hasta ese momento parecía algo
innecesario estaba y brindándome la
respuesta por una problemática en tiempo
real y por más simple que haya aparecido
esta situación el proceso mental que
tuve que hacer en ese momento fue
particularmente diferente a cualquier
cosa que había hecho en mi vida porque
es algo propio fue genuino y a partir de
ese momento se despertó algo en mí que
se ve que se había dormido por el simple
hecho de creer que yo no podía crecer
pude y me agarró esta locura por tratar
de conocer más sobre las cosas y sobre
la realidad
así que no para de buscar las
experiencias parecidas a este campamento
de fiel instituto balseiro convence a
mis amigos de la escuela para armar un
destilador de agua solar para un
concurso del conicet me metí en más
becas olimpiadas y campamentos para
seguir aprendiendo
y así que lo largo del año me dan el
título de la chica ciencia de la escuela
pero me pasó esto
me saqué un 7 en casi todas las materias
porque fue porque fui creciendo no dio a
que es normal que se vayan perdiendo
estos intereses a lo largo del tiempo y
más cuando esos chicos que de repente
llegas con un nuevo mundo lleno de
obligaciones y cosas que te quitan el
tiempo para lo que vos considera base
esencial
miren durante todos nuestros años de
secundaria para poder exhibir todas las
materias y pasar de año a todos los
chicos de la argentina se nos pide sacar
no más de un 6 17
y ahora yo me acuerdo que chiquita tenía
esta idea de la escuela como un lugar
exclusivo para aprender y no parar de
maravillarme con cosas nuevas
yo soñaba con ser astronauta porque esta
científica
me acuerdo que con mis amigas nos
poníamos a jugar a ser quiénes íbamos a
hacer de grandes
mi arroz yo siempre se ponía a dibujar
diciendo que alguna vez iba a ser
dibujante de películas animadas
hoy rocío tiene casi 19 años y empezó el
traductorado inglés
qué pasó durante esos 10 11 años de vida
con ese sueño
seguramente creció cambió de idea yo
cuenta que eso realmente no le gustaba
no era lo suyo
le pregunta y su respuesta fue algo así
como lo que pasa que diseño de animación
3d tiene mucha matemática
y yo siempre me la llevo
en cambio en inglés siempre me saque
buenas notas me es más fácil
y esto es así porque resulta que la
escuela es la única referencia oficial
que tenemos los chicos sobre nuestro
rendimiento intelectual y académico y
este es el resultado que puede tener una
simple calificación dentro del contexto
del sistema educativo
no dedicarte a lo que te apasiona
porque no solo te sacas un 3 o un 4
sos un 3 o un 4 y vas a seguir siendo
ese 3 s 4
las calificaciones nos terminan
clasificando del 1 al 10 2 5 10 bosh son
mejor que todos vós 1 y anda
preparándote para la que te espera
ahora esta paradoja de ser la chica
ciencia ya debe ser un 7 me hizo caer en
cuenta de que en realidad si terminas la
escuela y encima te animas a seguir una
carrera universitaria es muy probable
que caigas en todo eso que en una vez
nos enseñaron haces un balance de las
mejores notas que tuviste o de las
materias que más fácil estar resultaron
aprobar y simplemente buscas una carrera
que junte todo esto
entonces muchas veces lo que aprendemos
a pensar en la escuela es algo así como
si me es fácil sacarme buenas notas en
esto seguro me gusta y por lo tanto es
algo que me debería dedicar
y durante lo que te queda de secundaria
te enfocas simplemente en aprobar
termina pasando que los alumnos
aprendemos a ser alumnos y responder
únicamente con lo que se nos pide
pero aprender de verdad
no me queda eso
ha requerido mucho esfuerzo entender que
yo era más que mi nota soy más que esos
y cuando hice mis notas no cambiaron
mucho ahora lo que sí cambio es que
empecé a aprender
pero hasta qué punto poder revelar y
descuidar tus notas digo si podés evadir
las diciembre-marzo previas pero si tu
revolución te sale mal repetir de año
no podemos hacer esto solos necesitamos
ayuda el sistema educativo necesita un
cambio yo les puedo asegurar que la
pasión el interés que tiene esa chica
rocío mi amiga por el dibujo vale
muchísimo más que un 3 o un 4 en
cualquier materia
la escuela debería ser ese lugar que nos
enseñe a pensar a buscar eso que tanto
nos enamora
hacer de la manera que queremos ser y no
la que nos dicen los números que somos
hoy mi boletín seguirá diciendo que soy
17 si mis compañeros mis docentes y mi
establecimiento educativo seguirán
teniendo hasta contradictoria chica
ciencia llena de sietes
pero para mí
soy más que un número
ahora las calificaciones son algo
realmente útiles necesarias
no sé
pero mostrarnos durante todo nuestro
proceso educativo que somos y podemos
muchísimos más que esos números
estoy convencida de que eso es algo
indispensable
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]